elon musk is the charismatic ceo behind
spacex
tesla neuralink the boring company
and likely many others as well over the
years
elon and his outstanding team have
accomplished
several previously unthinkable tasks in
the space
and automotive industries and most would
agree
that many of these companies likely
wouldn't have survived without elon
at least not in the early stages thus
it's hard to imagine
elon musk getting fired from one of his
own companies
but like steve jobs and apple this is
precisely what happened with elon musk
as he was forced to resign as tesla's
chairman two years ago
and to this day he has yet to be rehired
so what happened
[Music]
well starting off as you may have
expected with individuals like elon musk
and donald
trump the entire conundrum originated on
twitter
prior to his incriminating tweet he had
been messing around with taunting tweets
for a couple of months at that point
most of these tweets were targeted
towards short sellers
who had short positions on tesla if
anyone doesn't know what short selling
is
the process itself is a bit complicated
but all you need to know is that people
who are short selling make money
when the stock price goes down so
essentially
these individuals are betting against
tesla
and of course if you're the ceo of a
public company
you aren't particularly fond of short
sellers
especially when they have made your
company the most shorted stock
on the market considering this elon
would often taunt short sellers
that they're going to lose millions if
not billions of dollars
when tesla stock skyrockets one such
tweet was
they have about three weeks before the
short position explodes
clearly elon was already walking pretty
close to the line
and this would blow up when he tweeted
and considering taking tesla private at
20 funding secured one thing to note
is that this figure is before the stock
split so
in today's stock prices elon basically
claimed that he had funding to take
tesla private
at 84 dollars per share this would have
been fine
if they had paperwork started and were
actually making serious progress towards
closing a deal
to make tesla private even then elon
really should just wait and make an
official statement
as opposed to posting on twitter at that
point
the deal to take tesla private was just
a proposal
and funding wasn't really secured elon
musk had some meetings with saudi
arabia's sovereign wealth fund
in regard to taking tesla private but
nothing was certain
in fact the purchase price of 420 was
kind of a meme
elon got the number by adding 20 to the
current stock price
which gave him 419 dollars and he
decided to add one dollar
because of april 20th but clearly the
security and exchange commission
didn't find it nearly as funny as elon
did to add fuel to the fire
elon later posted that the only reason
the deal may fall through
is because of shareholders voting to
decline the deal
right after elon tweeted these
statements tesla stock skyrocketed as
buyers flooded in
this makes sense as if funding really
was secured at 420 dollars
buying in at any price under 420 dollars
is basically guaranteed profit this
stock soared six percent
in less than an hour to 381 dollars
when the nasdaq decided to halt trading
of tesla stock
they did reopen trading however later
that day
which let the stock continue to rise and
it ended up a little under 400
the reason this is dangerous is because
such artificial rises in stock price
could result in a lot of investors
losing a lot of money
if the deal doesn't come to fruition if
the deal fails
the stock price will no doubt crash back
to where it was originally
if not even lower thus all of the
investors who bought in
on the false promise that tesla was
going private at 420
would have lost money consequently the
sec
charged elon as well as tesla for
securities fraud soon after
the sec actually offered elon and tesla
a settlement deal
according to the new york times this
deal apparently proposed that elon would
have to step down from being chairman
for two years
and pay a 10 million fine however
there was one detail that is thought to
have pushed elon away from taking the
deal
the settlement required that elon could
neither admit nor deny
whether he was actually guilty of
securities fraud since elon rejected the
deal
the sec launched a full-scale
investigation into elon
and tesla in august of 2018 and of
course
the sec determined that elon was indeed
guilty of securities fraud and they
charged him
and tesla 20 million dollars each elon
was fined for making the statement
and tesla was fined for failing to have
disclosure restrictions in place
which would have prevented elon from
posting such a venture on twitter
even if it was indeed finalized aside
from this
elon had to step down as tesla chairman
within 45 days
and could not be rehired for three years
as a result robin denholm replaced elon
musk as tesla chairman
in late 2018 and she is still tesla's
chairman today
and finally all of his public
communications regarding tesla
had to be overseen by tesla's board so
what was the long lasting impact of this
decision
well robin denholm has expressed that
shareholders want a more
boring musk but really not much has
changed
during the height of this event elon
musk actually went out to joe rogan's
podcast
and we all know what he did though this
isn't that big of a deal as it is
illegal in the state of california
this made many tesla employees quite mad
as they have to go through drug testing
moreover elon musk continues to post
whatever he wants
on twitter and he has even gone on air
stating that his tweets are rarely
overseen he states that only tweets that
may affect the stock price of tesla
have to be reviewed by tesla's board but
it doesn't seem like these are reviewed
either
as he has also admitted i i i want to be
clear i do not respect the sec
i do not respect them but but you're
abiding by the settlement aren't you
because i respect the justice system
with such an attitude
it's no question that nothing has really
changed
just this year elon tweeted tesla stock
price too high
imo this itself is not something that's
okay to say
as a public ceo and this no doubt
led to tesla stock crashing 10 within
minutes after the tweet
i'm honestly surprised that the sec did
not get involved with this one
but he did receive a lot of backlash
from his own twitter community
as many of them are heavy tesla
investors who lost tens of thousands of
dollars
if not hundreds of thousands of dollars
within hours
i think it's pretty clear why this is
not appropriate to say
even if it was true but if we take a
closer look at the tweet
we can see that it's actually much worse
than it seems
at first glance this tweet was posted on
5 1
2020 at 8 11 am pacific time
and guess what on august 11th a 5 to 11
stock split was announced
you get it 8 11 am august 11th
may 1st 2020 5 to 1 stock split elon
says stock price is too high
and the stock's place announced you can
definitely just dismiss this
as a bizarre coincidence but given that
it's from elon musk
i think we'd agreed that it was likely
much more than just a coincidence
so really elon basically leaked a stock
split
four months before it actually went
through if this theory could be proved
i'm sure the sec would not be happy
but even without proof that this is what
elon was up to
i don't think that the sec was very
happy nonetheless
after this we saw tesla short shorts
which were a pretty strong indication
that tesla was indeed profitable
during the second quarter of 2020 and
more recently
elon musk both hyped up and cool down
expectations
for tesla battery day for instance he
tweeted things like
many exciting things would be unveiled
on battery day and
before that he had claimed that battery
day was one of the most important days
in tesla's history but later on as
expectations were unnaturally inflated
he posted that these new innovations
will not make a serious difference
till 2022. evidently elon's tweets have
always been
and continue to be quite influential to
tesla stock price
and one of these tweets cost him his
position as chairman of tesla
for a minimum of three years we may very
well see him be reappointed
as tesla's chairman late next year but
in the meantime he'll just have to
settle with being ceo
personally as a small and young investor
with
just a couple of tesla shares i don't
mind eon's questionable tweets
honestly i find it kind of funny to see
how his tweets affect the market
and it's pretty interesting to try to
puzzle together what his cryptic tweets
mean
but of course i'm not the only person
investing in tesla
and it's definitely not okay to put
investors with tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands or even millions
of dollars in tesla
through such a roller coaster so for
their sake
i do think elon should pull in his
tweeting just a little bit
how do you guys feel about elon's
twitter episodes comment that down below
also if you guys thought this video
explained the situation well
then make sure to drop a like and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys
on the next one